[Musique]
passepp
Luc comme ça pour qu' rappelle de son
père J je
r Je mon
[Musique]
Coutau en tout comme nous qu' la prison
aller
bien ça va mon grand il faut faire vite
là parce qu'il bouge plus vous calme je
sais pas quoi faire Laurence je peux
rien faire lui il est innocent fallait y
penser avant quoi il fallait penser àant
vous avez donc agressé la surveillante
ici présente la nuit dernière vous êtes
dangereuse j'ai jamais fait de mal à mon
fils moi à partir de maintenant la
moindre petite infraction je convoquerai
le juge des
enfants sinon ta petite là sort bientôt
prépare la procédure pour la faire
adopter quoi calmezvous ah non mais je
veux pas qu'il aille dans un foyer all
au ciel quoi ça il en est pas question
faut vous prendre en main c'est tout il
veulent pas qu'on se PRDE en main ici
vous connaissez personne d'autre qui
pourrait garder votre fils
non va falloir me prouver pendant cette
année vous pouvez vous rinsérrer dit
qu'il fallait que je travaille pour
faire bien pour
Lucas toi aussi tu te laisses pas battre
mais c'est quoi C gueule de constipé
allez merde un petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sourire il a un vrai truc magique avec
Luca on donne de l'espoir il me donne de
la
force donne du sens là à tout ce
de
bordel me changeant
bien